[Musik]
nun ja warte zunächst ruhig allerseits
herzlich willkommen bei unserem neuen
easy german life format wie ihr seht
sitze ich gemütlich zu hause aber kari
und janisch sind für uns unterwegs bevor
ich sie hier in unseren stream hole ein
paar hinweise hinweis noch mal eins
schreibt doch mal in den chat wenn ihr
gerade live zuschaut von wo ihr uns
zuschaut ich bin sehr gespannt wo ihr in
der welt gerade seid nummer zwei ihr
werdet morgen oder später schon
untertitel finden unter diesem video
jetzt noch nicht denn wir sind gerade
live und das waren schon die hinweise
und ich würde sagen wir holen mal kari
und janosch ins bild und schauen wo sie
gerade stecken
ich höre euch wo steckt ihr wir sind
gerade an einem ort kannst du schon
raten wo wir sind ich weiß nicht genau
was man hier sieht
es sitte weihnachtlich und ein bisschen
grau und kommerziell aus soja das ist
der alexanderplatz in berlin hallo jana
und hey an alle auch wie geht es dir
heute ja nicht so gut frisch
manuell wie geht es dir mir geht es auch
sehr gut ich bin auch frisch und gut
drauf ja manuel wir sind heute zum
alexanderplatz gefahren das ist ein ganz
zentraler ort in berlin und hier gibt es
einen weihnachtsmarkt ich muss ehrlich
zugeben das ist nicht unser lieblingsort
hier denn wie du schon sagst der
alexanderplatz ist ein bisschen grau
nicht nur wegen des wetters heute hallo
heute ein mal hallo sagen wir sind
gerade leicht bei youtube ich habe
danach richtigen bekommen dass eine
benachrichtigung bekommen und dann hat
mein mann gesagt guck mal hier stehen
sie
perfekt
aus polen
bei unseren großeltern zu besuch das ist
ja schön und jetzt besucht ihr den
weihnachtsmarkt in berlin genau alle
weihnachtsmärkte ich denke in den lucia
weihnachtsmarkt
und wie findest du diesen
ja ich mag dann wie alle hier in berlin
weil hier ist die atmosphäre besonders
so super weihnachtlich uns ja perfekt
und jetzt hat ihr zum lustiger
weihnachtszeit
das ist einer der schönsten
weihnachtsmärkte in berlin der ist aber
auch am vollsten deswegen sind wir heute
nicht hin aber viel spaß dort ja danke
wie heißt du sonja von ihr habt einen
schönen tag
die leute ja das ist wirklich schön
außer sonja schauen uns gerade leute aus
argentinien zu halo octavio aus spanien
hallo paco
ich zeig mal hier ein paar
einblendungen das ist paco dann ist
mischa aus irland dabei stets aus peru
escon salo dabei
und ja ganz schön viele leute schauen
das ist wirklich fantastisch und
facebook zuschauer haben wir auch noch
lippi aus der schweiz
jane aus michigan also scrollt hier so
schnell vorbei dass ich gar nicht mehr
so schnell klicken kann sehr schön alle
dabei sein
ja wir gehen jetzt ein bisschen weiter
über den weihnachtsmarkt manuel
was kann man machen auf dem
weihnachtsmarkt ja das ist eine gute
frage geschenke kaufen hübsche waren
stände
bewundern essen man kann sehr viel essen
und trinken essen trinken man kann eine
karussell fahren beispiel da kann man
spaß haben wenn man ein kind ist aber
grundsätzlich wird von einem christen
erwartet dass er sich volllaufen lässt
und einfach gute zeit verbringt hier
dieses wort müssen wir erklären
volllaufen lassen janisch das ist eine
sehr praktische vokabel das heißt dass
man sehr viel alkohol trinkt ja nicht
was mich das denn jetzt gerne trinken
einen kaffee oder ein glühwein keinen
glühwein ich mag silber nicht aber ich
hoffe dass ich hier diesen hot
motto ja trinke und den trinke ich
allerdings ohne den schuss also ohne den
alkohol am steuer ist immer alkohol das
ist ein cocktail nicht bei mir ja ich
möchte gerne einen heißen marita ohne
alkohol trinken ich bin mir nicht sicher
bedienen ob es das hier gibt man
ja du denn gerne dass wir das jetzt
machen wir können jetzt einige sachen
hier ausprobieren genau ich würde mal
sagen holt euch mal was zu trinken und
während ihr euch etwas zu trinken holen
könnt ihr liebe zuschauerinnen und einen
eine frage schreiben in die kommentare
ich schaue gerade wenn ihr immer sehr
sich hier so ein bisschen in die seite
schaue dann schaue ich auf eure
kommentare
und dann könnt ihr gerne fragen stellen
oder wenn ihr möchtet ascari und janisch
etwas besonderes aus mal ausprobieren
oder machen oder sich anschauen dann
könnt ihr auch eine kleine mission in
den chat schreiben und
ja ich würde manuel sagt wir sollen uns
was zu trinken holen wären wir auf die
fragen von den zuschauern waren wollen
wir das machen
und was ist denn das bekannteste getränk
was man normalerweise auf dem gewand auf
dem jetzt habe ich schon gesagt auf dem
wein trinkt
ich würde sagen ja nun wohl du uns doch
mal was zu trinken für mich zb einen
glühwein aber lieber noch einen apfel
wunsch werden sie ihre april will ich
auch
doch der lorenz kann auf was trinken so
carré d'or ist jetzt schon einen
glühwein bestellt das ist ja so das
bekannteste
getränk kannst du das kurz beschreiben
und dann habe ich eine frage für dich
also man trinkt traditionell lasst uns
ein bisschen weiter rüberkommen heißt es
sehr laut hier an der am glühweinstand
man trinkt traditionell glühwein auf dem
weihnachtsmarkt das ist eigentlich roter
wein der warm gemacht wird es mit
gewürzen und ich persönlich bin kein
glühwein florenz bist du einfach nur
manchmal wenn er gut gemacht
also wenn er gut gemacht ist trinkt
lorenz ist heute hinter der kamera
sollte ich mal vorstellen nur 1 hier ist
lorenz
lorenz hinter der kamera ja ansonsten
gibt es
auch andere getränke es gibt zum
beispiel apfelpunsch das hätte ich gerne
das ist eigentlich heißer apfelsaft auch
mit gewürzen und manchmal auch mit
alkohol ok
apropos essen
ja hiking fragt was kochst du kari zu
weihnachten dieses jahr ich koche gar
nichts zu weihnachten das macht meine
mutter so dass ich dann ja auch gar nix
wochen manuell und was wird deine mutter
kochen dieses jahr weißt du das schon
ehrlich gesagt weiß ich das noch nicht
wir diskutieren jeden weihnachten und
oft machen wir raclette das ist ein
französisches oder ich bin mir nicht
sicher kommt raclette aus der schweiz
ich glaube es kommt aus der schweiz real
das ist also eine tradition in der
schweiz die man auch in deutschland
gerne macht man hat dort so kleine
pannen und kann dort gemüse fleisch rein
wegen und mit käse überbacken und
ein sehr interaktives gericht das stimmt
so dann fragt john welchen
weihnachtsmarkt könnt ihr empfehlen in
berlin ist der weihnachtsmarkt auf dem
alexanderplatz empfehlenswert also der
alexanderplatz weihnachtsmarkt ist finde
ich nicht so empfehlenswert wir sind
hier hingegangen weil es der
alexanderplatz ist dass es ein bekannter
platz ist es aber immer sehr touristisch
und ist es jetzt gerade sehr leer was
gut für uns ist weil wir wollten nicht
in so eine enge menge gehen den
weihnachtsmarkt den ich am meisten
empfehlen kann ist der st lucia
weihnachtsmarkt in der kulturbrauerei
dort ist es sehr skandinavisch es gibt
viele händler aus verschiedenen
skandinavischen ländern oder ist janosch
mit getränken hallo janisch du hast ja
was leckeres mitgebracht
das ist absolut wunsch
auch manuell es gibt eine masken pflicht
auf dem weihnachtsmarkt und wie du
siehst hängt meine maske jetzt hier und
man muss maske tragen es sei denn man
trinkt etwas
[Gelächter]
bevorzugen der säufer schon wieder ein
jantscher gekauft das was ihr aber ohne
super lecker
wie schön der livestream erzählt du mal
weiter und wir machen eine kurze pause
er trinkt trinkt mal euren apfelpunsch
und währenddessen können wir mal kurz
auf ein bild von oben schauen wie es
hier aussieht also das ist jetzt kein
bild aus dem winter das ist im sommer
schnell macht aber das ist der
alexanderplatz auf dem ihr jetzt gerade
steht und dieser platz ist also mitten
in berlin
gehört noch zu berlin mitte und hat auch
eine längere geschichte wir können
später mal noch bilder zeigen dies da
früher aussah und
ganz in der nähe vom alexanderplatz ist
der fernsehturm und das ist der höchste
das höchste gebäude in deutschland
karimi ist es wollt ihr gleich noch den
fernsehturm uns zeigen
nein ich meine maske mit dem kabel
auseinander gefummelt und jetzt höre ich
dich wieder wir wollen euch gleich den
fernsehturm zeigen ja er ist jetzt
hinter einem gebäude verschwunden aber
wir werden jetzt hier auf trinken und
dann werden wir den weihnachtsmarkt
verlassen und euch ein bisschen mehr vom
alexanderplatz zeigen grundsätzlich ist
der alexanderplatz eine sehr große
fläche hast du vielleicht gerade gezeigt
auf der karte und
saisonal wird hier immer irgendwas
gemacht also weihnachten ist hier der
weihnachtsmarkt es gibt aber auch
verschiedene andere märkte die im jahr
hier sind ich glaube es gibt auch zu
ostern etwas es gibt immer zu den
verschiedenen feiertagen gibt es hier
was denn ja es ist ein sehr zentraler
platz wieder menschen kommen hierher und
es ist ja auch ein historisch besonderer
platz früher war das hier das zentrum
von ostberlin und ja wir sind immer noch
sehr viele geschäfte und viel ist hier
los und du hast gerade schon gesagt der
alexanderplatz ist sehr touristisch ich
glaube das ist ein ort wo man als
tourist schnell hin kommt weil es mitten
in berlin ist und so groß und bekannt
aber ein als berliner ist man da
eigentlich sehr selten oder
ungerne ist man dort das ist ein schönes
wort was gut dazu passt man ist also
nicht gerne auf dem alexanderplatz auch
in der u bahnstation nicht so gerne es
ist einfach so ein umstiegs punkt ein
platz wo sehr viele menschen
zusammenkommen und der alexanderplatz
selber der ist sehr ja wie kann man die
architektur beschreiben manuel sehr grau
sehr
um klassische sozialistische architektur
ist das eigentlich ist es ist manchmal
sehr schön aber ist es auch sehr viel
abstand und dadurch dass hier sehr viele
touristen sind kommen die meisten
berliner eher ungern gehen würde ich
sagen richtig ja es gibt auch schon
einen kommentar von mag der sagt besucht
die weltzeituhr bitte und besonders ich
nicht ob wir das jetzt schaffen aber auf
dem alexanderplatz gibt es eine
weltzeituhr das ist ja vielleicht kann
könnte das gleich kurz zeigen aber wie
können wir darüber zeigen man sieht sie
allerdings von hier nicht aber so seht
ihr ungefähr wie es hier aussieht hinten
gibt es so ein großes ja wie nennt man
denn das diesen turm dort
ja das ist ein brunnen glaube ich oder
das ist doch das ist so ein ding was man
auch weihnachten was ja siehst du wir
kennen die eigenen traditionen nicht nur
ganz fest wie das heißt leider nicht
ok vorne links sehen wie er guckt sich
gerade in einem stand für brieftaschen
um
und wie ihr seht ist hier noch nicht so
viel los wahrscheinlich wird sich das
später ändern nämlich so vielleicht in
ein zwei stunden ist hier etwas mehr los
wenn vielleicht ein paar besucher hier
sind wenn die leute nicht mehr arbeiten
dann kommen sie hin und treffen sich zum
glühweintrinken ja
ja ja wie ist das denn dürfte das
getränk jetzt mitnehmen und euch schon
auf den weg machen oder möchte das ist
das problem ich würde gerne gehen aber
ich muss noch trinken habe nicht kannst
du mir helfen
könnten ja ich will kein alkohol
ja ich habe das gefühl es geht gar nicht
lärmen oder ich trinke noch die hälfte
und dann gehen wir ok dann stelle ich
euch noch ein paar fragen
es gibt jetzt fragen kommen wir hier im
jahr aber es gibt schon die erste
challenge von nada und zwar möchte sie
gerne dass ihr ein oder zwei
weihnachtslieder vor sinkt wir sollen
weihnachtslieder singen kannst kannst du
singen leider nicht und auch keine weine
reiseriesen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich schon vergessen weißt du
weiter lorenz
weihnachtlich
[Musik]
tannenbaum
du grüßt nicht nur zur sommerzeit nein
auch im winter wenn es schneit wie
gewünscht der weihnachtsbaum der
tannenbaum ist doch grün dass das ganze
jahr über grün den vix gabelungen
wünschen wir einen tabulosen und grünen
ist dass mit grunzen zu tun er ist grün
das war der witz in
[Musik]
der jagst du heute zu unserem besuch auf
dem weihnachtsmarkt ja es gibt noch ein
paar fragen zum
papier zu verschwenden geben sie die in
die currywurst in so gebackenen
janisch es gibt einige fragen ja es gibt
noch ein paar fragen zum weihnachtsmarkt
erstmal sagt merkel das worüber wir
gerade gesprochen haben könnte eine
weihnachtspyramide sein das kann nur
einer sein
grund es gibt ein paar fragen dazu was
es auf dem weihnachtsmarkt außer essen
und trinken noch gibt zum beispiel fragt
diana welches souvenirs gibt es auf dem
weihnachtsmarkt die man nach russland
schicken könnte weil da ein vorschlag
wir könnten mal ganz kurz rüber gehen
und das angucken
hatte mal jetzt müssen uns ganz kurz
koordinieren wir zeigen euch jetzt
eigentlich das souvenir so lorenz hat
auch schon ausgetrunken du rennst du
bist schnell
zu sagen vielleicht kann ja nicht mal
kurz rüber gehen und wenn jetzt zeigen
was auch schon die maske an
souvenirs zu zeigen
also hier stehen wir vor einem typischen
souvenirstand
und hier kann man ganz viele
niedliche süße figürchen kaufen die
kosten zehn euro zum beispiel acht euro
die ganz kleinen kosten drei euro
fünfzig
und die kann man sich dann später
irgendwo zu hause
hinstellen und sich freuen und
beschreibung
und wir haben hier auch sachen die ich
kaum beschreiben kann und auch mir
völlig unbekannt sind aber umso besser
umso interessanter ist wird das und wir
können noch
die glaube kari villiers übernehmen will
ich das okay
mit den kopfhörern ist immer so eine
sache ich zeige euch nochmal was kommt
man mit ihre war
und zwar einmal hier gibt es grotenburg
schneeballen das ist so ein besonderes
gebäck das haben wir schon mal
vorgestellt vor zwei jahren da waren
lisa und maria in rotenburg erinnerst du
dich ja klar natürlich
dieses geschmack immer noch im und
richtig so süß dass es dich vom hocker
zieht willst du dir einkaufen nein bitte
nicht ich jetzt nicht eingehen wir mal
weiter
zeigt euch noch was
und zwar
dann ich möchte eine mütze an problemen
das können wir gleich auch zeigen ich
wollte euch mal das hier zeigen das ist
ein typischer laden wo es so
holzspielzeug gehalts dekoration das ist
ein gutes geschenk wenn man geschenke
sucht für für andere länder weil das es
wirklich sehr typisch deutsch das gibt
es nicht in allen ländern das weiß aber
nicht ob man das gut nach russland
schicken kann muss man gut verpacken wir
können wir weiter gucken hier aber du
musst das noch erklären also da kommt
eine kerze unten rein und jan dadurch
dritten klasse hitze macht dreht sich
dann das rad oben und unten definieren
und kommen zb vier kerzen und oben dreht
sich das dann
haste 1190 euro
wieviel 190 war es ein bisschen zu jahr
aber handgemacht wahrscheinlich
was haben wir denn hier
was ist das das ist
ich habe das wort vergessen der
nussknacker haben skater kann man mit
dem nussknacker machen ein märchen für
kinder
ich kann da nicht auch die nüsse knacken
ok mama ich glaube wir verlassen jetzt
den weihnachtsmarkt was hältst du davon
davon halte ich sehr viel zeigt uns mal
ein bisschen wie der alexanderplatz
sonst noch aussieht wir müssen ja
zumindest den fernsehturm nochmal zeigen
ja das war schön dass wir mal ein
weihnachtsmarkt gesehen haben ich möchte
nochmals zur einordnung sagen dass yahoo
weihnachtsmarkt am alexanderplatz nicht
der schönste weihnachtsmarkt deutschland
das karussell geht los
das ist ja
also es gibt sehr viel schönere
weihnachtsmärkte sowohl in berlin und
gerade auch so in kleineren städten oder
in dörfern in deutschland da gibt es
manchmal so richtig schöne traditionelle
weihnachtsmärkte da steht dann nicht so
eine große mülltonne darum
und da gibt es dann wirklich
handgemachte sachen und so menschen die
wirklich dinge verkaufen die sie selbst
herstellen also das ist dann noch etwas
schöner und traditioneller eine sekunde
manuel ich muss doch war hier mit meinen
kopfhörern herumhampeln
lorenz kann uns ja mal schnell jahren
zeigen
manuel
ich bin jedoch aus dem weihnachtsmarkt
raus ich konnte
meine maske abnehmen und jetzt kann ich
die mal zeigen wie es hier außerhalb des
weihnachtsmarkt aussieht
zeigen euch gleich die schöne uhr aber
ansonsten ich zeig mal ganz kurz wie es
hier aussieht ist es grau es ist eine
baustelle
es sind große graue gebäude
es ist sehr viel platz sehr viel abstand
und hier seht ihr die polizeiwache die
wache am alexanderplatz dieses neue oder
die gibt es seit ein paar jahren weil
hier gibt es leider auch wenn hier
nachts viele menschen sind brauchen wir
auch die polizei
ja was kann man zum alexanderplatz noch
sagen vielleicht geben wir mal ein
bisschen weiter darüber da fährt gerade
die tram mitten durch den platz hier
durch wie du siehst ich habe extra
langsam genau haben sie sich nur verkehr
für fußgänger und für die tram es gibt
keine autos auf dem alexanderplatz
richtig und wie du siehst geht dort der
weihnachtsmarkt weiter und dort sieht er
auch viel schöner aus wird gibt es
holzhütten es gibt die pyramide da steht
auch der pyramiden trades also jetzt
seht ihr doch noch mal wie ich das
aussieht
und molly paul merkt an
nicht so schön der alex ist ziemlich
hässlich das ist übrigens ein guter
punkt die berliner nennen den
alexanderplatz alex einfach nur alex wir
sind auf dem alex oder wir treffen uns
um alles
jan ich möchte jetzt die uhr vorstellen
ich gebe mal ich übergebe ich hier mal
ja ja das ist jetzt also die weltzeituhr
ein beliebter treffpunkt auch für
berliner der allerdings eine gewisse
ironie nicht entbehrt weil die
narben sind danke all die
ddr regierung hat diese wunderschöne uhr
ihrem volk geschenk dazu gelangen weil
das volk ja das land nicht verlassen
dürfte dann dürfte er sich dann eine
welt oder zumindest angucken
ok interessant das ist die geschichte
der weltzeituhr
llanos anfragt ob du heute schlecht
gelaunt bist oder kommt ihm das nur so
vor
ich bin nicht schlecht gelaunt aber
ehrlich gesagt
alexanderplatz
macht mich immer so ein bisschen
traurig ich weiß nicht warum
und wie man muss auch einmal das ganze
gesehen haben ja und mk wollte noch
wissen oder hätte sich noch gewünscht
dass du aufs karussell gehst das ist
jetzt schade zu spät dabei hatte ich
richtig lust darauf zu zeigen
machen wir beim nächsten mal
wollt ihr mal jeder biografie wider
jawohl
heute stellen sich das ok harnisch es
schlecht gelaunt kein thema das ändern
wir jetzt ich habe total gute laune
waren weil was möchtest du als nächstes
von uns wissen wollt ihr mal in richtung
fernsehturm gehen dass wir lassen ja
wollen wir zeigen einmal den ganzen turm
von hier sieht man die nämlich
haben die
phänomen
zeigt mal ganz kurz janisch hat fand
marken bekommen das müsst ihr euch
merken wenn irgendwie auf dem
weihnachtsmarkt seit oder irgendwo wo
man gläser bekommt kriegt man fand
marken und da muss man die gläser mit
den pfandmarken oder hörst gerade
unseren podcast gehört ich bin deine
mutter
es ist unglaublich es ist wirklich
unglaublich du wieder in der superstar
ist wie drei monate hier an ich kenne
dich muss solange ich komme aus chile
ich habe nur deutsch gelernt weil und
kathrin weiß wo wir sind gerade auf
youtube schicchi mal grüße von mir und
ein paar hundert zuschauer youtube
manu ist gerade mit uns verbunden er
schickt dir grüße
größe für dich
ich liebe dich alles danke danke das
freut uns total dass du
tage dass
heute die partie kommst du ja ich komme
ja dazu ließen unsere
alles mal die vokabel hilft sagt mal
dass man dass man sie mangels fragt
optimal die vokabel hilfe zeigen kannst
von unserem podcast bisschen näher mit
der kamera
also dieses jahr sehr hilfreich für mich
also muss man mal sagen du bist gerade
zufällig vorbeigekommen
bist du denn deutsche wagen
ich glaube
ich habe
da war
sich zu treffen
das war doch abgesprochen kari das war
doch
wir müssen das jetzt kurz erklären also
was er gerade gezeigt hat ist die
vokabel hilfe die bekommt ihr unter
anderem wenn ihr ein mitglied von uns
werdet auf petra und dann bekommt ihr zu
unserem podcast diese vokabel hilfe und
ein interaktives transkript und die
weihnachtsfeier von der er gerade sprach
die findet in ein paar tagen statt mit
allen unseren mitgliedern das heißt wenn
wir jetzt noch einen mitglied werdet von
easy german wir blenden euch mal hier
den link ein wo das geht dann könnt ihr
dieses wochenende noch eine virtuelle
weihnachtsfeier mit uns feiern wir
würden dann feiert mit uns online im
internet manuel ich möchte noch kurze
ende sagen dass mit dem fanden ja so
typisch in deutschland man bekommt eine
landmarke und die muss man zurückgeben
wie viele stand hast du bezahlt ich weiß
es nicht aber ziemlich viel weil ich
habe für diese drei getränke 20 euro
bezahlt ja und ich glaube ich das ist
wahrscheinlich fünf euro stücken er
wahrscheinlich kriegst du einen euro
zurück mit dieser fand merkel für das
glas und wir haben sie einfach stehen
lassen
und was man ja ich möchte dir noch einen
bekannten anblick zeigen vom
alexanderplatz und zwar ist dass der
bahnhof alexanderplatz der ist also
zwischen dem platz und dem turm ist
einer der größten bahnhöfe in berlin und
dort fahren die s-bahnen oben und unten
die u bahnen und auf der straße die tram
also drei verschiedene verkehrsmittel
treffen sich hier aus ganz berlin kommen
sie hier zusammen und wenn man in berlin
wundern muss man hier ziemlich oft
vorbei und kann hier umsteigen da kommt
ran sie wird jetzt direkt an uns
vorbeifahren ich zeig mal kurz wie der
bahnhof früher aussah so um die
jahrhundertwende herum also
1904 ist dieses bild glaube ich
entstanden damals gab es noch kutschen
aber da gab es auch schon die tram und
da sieht man diesen bahnhof der wurde
zwar im krieg zerstört hier sieht man
wie der alexanderplatz nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg aussah also sehr viel
zerstörung natürlich durch den krieg und
ja mittlerweile ist natürlich alles
modernisiert und neu
aufgebaut
manuel ich ärgere mich jetzt gerade
immer noch über die pfandmarken die wir
nicht zurückgebracht haben ja das ist
vielleicht könnt ihr die gleich
verschenken und jemand an der die gläser
findet man kann dir nur mit den gläsern
zurückgeben und ihr haben wir stehen
lassen
gut ja okay so jetzt verlasst ihr also
den alexanderplatz und geht in richtung
fernsehturm der schon offiziell nicht
mehr auf dem alexanderplatz steht
sondern richtig daneben
tram fährt hier um die ecke und das
macht ja wir gehen jetzt zum fernsehturm
war es heute man hier auf dem weg
typische geschäfte am alexanderplatz
döner und pizza
fisch und chips
es gibt viel sehr viel zu essen hier
sehr viele
touristische orte würde ich mal sagen
und es ist sehr laut guckt da kommt
schon die nächste tram total viel
gemacht ja es ist ein echter
umschlagplatz also man steigt um von
u-bahn zu tragen genau es ist vor allem
eigentlich ein großer bahnhof auf dem
man hin und her geht so und wir gehen
jetzt gleich rüber zu dem turm der ist
jetzt allerdings auf der anderen seite
von hier
müssen wir erstmal warten bis die dramen
weggefahren ist ja ich bin noch da wie
geht es dir in jan schüttes zu dicht
sehr gut wie fühlst du dich am
alexanderplatz ja viele krimis
spielt sich heute gut aber er zeigt es
nicht so
achter es ist doch schön wenn ja soll
ich euch noch ein paar fragen und
den ausblick von berlin von oben können
wir gerade nicht hochfahren aber wir
sind jetzt fast da du rennst du kannst
anzeigen wenn ihr die ganzen trans
vorbeifahren dann geht es hier hoch zum
fernsehturm und was hast du über den
fernsehschirm zu erzählen
ratet mal wieder es wurde quasi noch von
der
ddr regierung gebaut und sie waren
natürlich mächtig stolz darauf aber
als die sonne angefangen hat zu scheinen
ist der
abglanz von der sonne in der kugel also
der abglanz der sonne in der kugel
ergibt ein kreuz und darüber lachten
natürlich alle war ja die ddr-regierung
strikte anti
katholisch oder anti religiös war und
dann haben sie sich selber so ein
eigentor geschossen
also in der kugel von dem turm spiegelt
sich ein kreuz das aussieht wie ein
christliches kreuz mit und das war nicht
die intention der regierung sondern
einen zufall
architektur zu fallen manuel hat eine
frage für uns um zwei sonnen geraten wie
hoch der turm es
357 meter ich bin total schlechteren
sowas zu raten ehrlich gesagt also die
gebäude die hier darum herum stehen die
sind vielleicht auch
ich habe gar keine ahnung 30 meter hoch
ich schätze mal
200 meter
also janisch lag ich kann es kaum
glauben nur elfmeter daneben ja schon
war die 68 meter
die aus den fingern gezogen gezogen du
wirst das gar nichts absolut nicht wahr
es in lotterie rating
und es ist damit der das höchste gebäude
in deutschland und immerhin der
vierthöchste fernsehturm in europa das
wohngebäude in deutschland acht ist das
höchste gebäude in deutschland aber da
ist ja oben noch so eine ganz hohe
antenne drauf die den natürlich noch mal
sehr viel höher macht als da wo die
kugel ist aber
das ist das höchste gebäude in
deutschland yahoo sich
nicht aber den fernsehturm kann man
wirklich überall sehen wenn man in
berlin unterwegs ist den fernsehturm
sieht man so gut fahren in jeder ecke
hat man das gefühl vor allem in ost
berlin sieht man den tatsächlich sind
die straßen teilweise so also der ist so
gebaut worden die straßen waren meistens
feuerchen da aber der turm steht so dass
man den in jeder straße fast sieht das
ist schon bemerkenswert also wenn man
bei uns zum beispiel die straße runter
geht und wir wohnen schon einige
kilometer weg von dem turm sieht man den
immer noch ja
ja so ich wollte noch mal hier grüße
schicken der kommentar schon vorbei aber
tatsächlich kam gerade ein kommentar von
chelsea in der tram saß die gerade
vorbeigefahren ist nein wirklich
liebe monster treibt uns grüße aus der
tram die gerade bei uns vorbeigefahren
ist
und ja ich glaube wir müssen auch bald
schon zum ende kommen was wollt ihr uns
denn zum abschluss noch zeigen
vielleicht können wir dir noch die
verkehrsregeln hier zeigen auf dem
alexanderplatz mal sehen ob man davon in
deutschland geriet ist ja einige regeln
das hier ist offensichtlich eine
geschützte grünanlage dafür dass das
hier eine grünanlage gibt ist gibt es
hier sehr wenig grün vielleicht fans
noch immer rum schwenken
lorenz man sieht es gibt ein paar bäume
die haben jetzt keine blätter mehr das
ist also hier in berlin eine geschützte
grünanlage
außerdem ist ja hunde sind an zu leihen
fußballspielen ist verboten und was
heißt das
deshalb ist es grün das heißt es ihre
java radfahren ist in ordnung mit
fahrradfahren ist auf befestigten wegen
erlaubt fußgänger haben aber vorrang das
heißt wenn der fußgänger kommt musst du
zuerst durch der verzehr von alkohol und
das rauchen sind verboten
zuwiderhandlungen werden geahndet
kein alkohol auf dem alexanderplatz das
ist
ja gesehen wir haben ja selber gerade
alkohol getrunken
früher war der alexanderplatz auch sehr
beliebt bei skateboardern also in der
ddr zeit da die ersten skater in
deutschland die haben da viel auf diesem
platz unter dem turm also eigentlich
nicht der alexanderplatz sondern da
direkt unter dem turm da wurde früher
viel gestartet wir sind ja direkt unter
dem turm vielleicht können wir uns das
noch mal zeigen wie nah wie jetzt am
turm dran sind direkt hier vorne ist der
turm und von hier geht es also ganz nach
oben in den den höchst der höchste turm
deutschlands ich hab's wirklich nicht
gewusst ich bin überrascht und sagt mal
normen möchte wissen ob der noch benutzt
wird um das fernsehsignal wirklich zu
übertragen
was ja heute nicht mehr so das wäre gut
wenn ich das wüsste ich weiß es aber
nicht hallo ich weiß das weil ja auch
nicht keine ahnung ja das kann ich dir
leider nicht sagen
ja machen heißt ich nicht wie fandest du
jetzt diesen rundgang hier am
alexanderplatz sehr schön ich sehe es so
ein bisschen so wie janisch also der
alexanderplatz ist nicht der schönste
ort in berlin aber es ist ein wichtiger
ort man ist als berliner ab und zu da
wenn man um steigt als tourist kommt man
dahin um auf den turm zu gehen ich
glaube der fernsehturm da hochzufahren
mit dem aufzug kostet 15 euro oder so
deswegen erstes jetzt nicht was was man
heute war das werden wir machen ich habe
mir schon ein architektur guide buch
gekauft
im stande zu sein die gebäude die wir
dann sehen sonst außer ein bisschen zu
beschreiben ich möchte allerdings euch
noch einen tipp geben wenn ihr nach
berlin kommt vielleicht kann lorenz ist
einmal zeigen dann würde ich nicht auf
den turm fahren sondern auf das park inn
das hat auch ein panorama deck oben und
von dort aus hat man nämlich auch einen
guten überblick über berlin plus man
sieht noch den turm dazu und das ist ein
sehr schöner überblick über die stadt
was für ein gewinn leute
hier beiden manuel haben wir den
alexanderplatz gut repräsentiert mit
algen schönheiten in perfekt
repräsentiert und gezeigt und ich würde
sagen schön dass ihr alle dabei rat was
sagt man am ende von so einem livestream
abonnieren nicht vergessen abonnieren
klickt die glocke klingelt dann bei euch
und
meldet euch gerne an als mitglied von
the german das wäre für uns ein das
schönste weihnachtsgeschenk damit
unterstützt er unsere arbeit und ihr
seid bei der weihnachtsfeier dabei am
wochenende genau da freue ich mich drauf
und ist
daher freue ich mich aber auch das ist
eben genau am freitag sehen wir euch
viele von euch zu unserer
weihnachtsfeier ich freue mich schon
darauf bis bald kommt